today we're talking about user-friendly
sql cloud scheduler and cyber security
and healthcare i'm nicola and welcome to
this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news
we're expanding bigquery's commitment to
user-friendly sql through a whole slew
of new sql features from expanded sql
expressions and scripting control
statements to expanded data types and
information schema views we're making
bigquery easier for you to use check out
the blog for more reliably executing
tasks on schedule is critical for
everything from data engineering to
infrastructure management and
application maintenance today we are
thrilled to announce the google cloud
scheduler our enterprise grade
scheduling service is now available in
more gcp regions
in addition multiple regions can now be
used from a single project removing the
prior limits of a single region per
project
with all the crises that have buffeted
the health care and life science
industries over the past two years one
that often gets overlooked is the
unceasing wave of cyber attacks aimed at
medical
research educational and public health
organizations
the best way to put an end to these
persistent threats to improve the
resilience of healthcare organizations
it systems
they might do well to look at their own
industry for inspiration and an approach
akin to exposure therapy check out the
blog for more details
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you